welcome back questioning president
Trump's mental fitness for office is
becoming a vicious relentless obsession
of the left so I asked Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell about that in
part two of our exclusive interview
tonight two different cable networks
today MSNBC and CNN at different points
in the day we're raising serious
questions I mean these are big big
leagues reporters about the mental state
of President Trump implying or not just
coming up like saying that he looks like
he has early onset dementia he's
unstable
he's destructive he's an imbalanced at a
time where we could very well be facing
a war with North Korea you've had a lot
of interactions of the president tell us
about what you view his intellectual
mental capacity those accusations are
absolutely outrageous I'm asked to speak
to the president of virtually daily
basis and I'm involved with him all the
time on all these issues and that kind
of accusation is totally baseless and
outrageous I mean it's so personal and
it's someone who my father had dementia
and it's personal to me and yet these
charges are being thrown around a lot of
people believe as a precursor to perhaps
a Democrat takeover into it 2018 and
then ultimately a push to try to remove
him from office that feeling is in this
building the Democrats want want to
invalidate this election one way or
another look I think those kind of
accusations are completely off based and
irresponsible let's argue over the
issues we have different points of view
for example the decision to get on the
tax bill was totally partisan every
Democrat said I don't want to do tax
reform every Republican said I do that's
the appropriate area for us to have our
discussions in public about the future
of the country I'm moving on to the
government funding government shutdown
Chuck Schumer has actually said as much
that he'd be willing to move to have the
government shutdown he wouldn't blame
himself but have the government shutdown
over amnesty
for dhaka the dreamers and yet in 2013
he said this don't hold the American
people hostage simply because you're so
sure you are right and everyone else is
wrong
well this is a political suicide for the
Democrats to shut the government down
over amnesty for illegal yeah that'd be
pretty dumb place for them to end up and
I don't think in the end they will end
up there the president has has said he's
open to a daca deal Tom cotton senator
Perdue have this idea of the raise act
which would have a whole bunch of things
in it including ending chain migration
which is like a 70/30 issue it's really
not a political issue you know every
Mexican who comes into United States on
average brings six family members for
every two green card holders or legal
immigrants they bring in seven so most
Americans are say that that's too much
would you tonight commit to making that
part of any future daca amnesty yeah I
agree with cotton and Perdue the
president has given us to March to deal
with the issue of daca and the question
is whether you're just going to do that
and nothing else I'm in favor of doing
something on the daca front these kids
came here there's no act of their own I
think they have a legitimate case to be
made but I don't think we're to just do
that a chain migration doing something
about that diversity lottery there are
plenty of changes to the legal
immigration system it should be added to
any kind of a daca fix that we do do you
think the election was it was a mandate
on passing immigration policies that are
geared more toward the American worker
would you agree with that well I think
clearly immigration the president made
that a front and center issue I mean the
wall which we're still trying to achieve
for him was only part of it and I think
there is a great interest in changing
the legal immigration system by the way
I'm sure you share my view that legal
immigration is important my wife the
Secretary of Transportation came here at
age eight not speaking a word of English
and legal immigration has been an
important part
of America for over 200 years our entire
nation
yeah our entire existence that doesn't
mean you just let anybody in at any
point and it doesn't mean you tolerate
illegal entries so the president's
actually given us an opportunity here by
saying he wants to fix daca but he
doesn't want it all by itself he wants
something with it and I think the kinds
of things you and I are discussing that
cotton and Perdue pushing or exactly
what part of it what ought to be part of
a solution the tweets today from
President Trump one about the sexual
harassment case at NBC another he
retweeted Muslim Muslim vid that Muslim
videos where there was violence in them
and apparently the source was someone a
lot of people in Britain thing is kind
of an unsavory figure do do these tweets
make it more difficult for you to get
stuff done here in Congress yeah I'm not
gonna critique the president tweeting
habits they've been much discussion
about that all year it's his decision
but shimmerin Pelosi didn't show up at
the meeting of course yesterday he had
two empty chairs which I actually kind
of like the empty chair senator I think
that was actually clarifying it it
certainly keeps things lively I'd be
remiss answering one other question I'm
sorry North Korea this is getting
extremely tense if it wasn't tense
before would you urge the Senate and to
be able to vote on a use of force
military force if we're indeed getting
involved in the Korean Peninsula well if
it gets to that I think the president
doing actually a great job he's the
first presidents been able to get the
attention of the Chinese who were
actually squeezing the North Koreans as
we speak are you hopeful we can avert
war and Peninsula senator thank you for
all this time thank you Eric come back
soon